um yeah my talk will be about something
that I call Big Ed L framework it's got
got a name called peach box and yeah I
will guide you through this first I
would like to start with a few word
about myself and my history and what's
actually the motivation of why I'm doing
what I'm doing I was also in particle
physics um working at Daisy and Hamburg
working at a colloid experiment and even
at that time I was doing data analysis
data analytics and I a lots of computing
and that was already like a big data
problem because you know this pollution
take place at a rate of 40 megahertz and
then the detector detects all kinds of
stuff and you get an event that has
quite some quite some data so at least
back then the experiment in Hamburg was
still quite big and you can consider
this a big data problem many events of
the same structure and even at that time
like the computing infrastructure wasn't
really really good so we had a cluster
of computers and we were writing our
analytics code and then we had to
schedule the jobs by ourselves so there
was no no resource manager nothing like
that just a queue or you could send your
jobs and there was a free slot it got
computed and you got your answer back
and you actually had to put the results
together and yeah actually so every
researcher had to had to deal with this
and was no general solution to this so
so everybody actually developed is
private solution to this problem so
there were like hundreds of solutions
for paralyzing on these computations
after any left academics my studies
working in an attack
company we were doing real-time bidding
so it was a startup and there was
nothing in the beginning and yeah I was
supposed to develop their their
framework their data processing and I
thought hey that's a good fit I'm coming
from particle physics and the data
actually has a similar structure so you
have a lot of events like they're all of
the same structure and yeah you want to
get signals out of it for example to
predict prices for potential banner
placements and at that time Hadoop came
up and was like a very interesting
technology and I thought hey um I do
that's great you have a framework you
just need to define your map function at
your reduce function and you can send it
to your Hadoop cluster and and you know
perfect world I'm very easy everything
so everything seem better but it was
actually not yeah because technology can
be great but it doesn't actually solve
all your problems especially not in this
case because building a data system
means a lot more than just you know
having data and sending it to a cluster
we do cluster or spark or whatever
getting the answer back and you know um
it involves much more for example
modeling your data I'm defining your
tasks I'm scheduling your tasks built a
system that is fault tolerant so
something goes wrong and how do you
recover your system and all that um yeah
so
actually I was working at this attack
company for almost two years or so and I
wasn't quite happy there you know
because CTOs tend to look for on like
quick solutions so they see a problem
and then they look for a technology want
to apply it and think then they're done
and yeah I was even back then trying to
approach this in a more your integral
way to develop a system which also runs
in the long-term run and yeah after I
left this company I started working as
freelance data scientists and kind of
specialized into these data processing
systems also and have seen that like a
lot of companies actually do have this
problem so you heard in the in the talk
by Felix for example if you look at the
the problem setting you know how
companies usually have data and they
want to do something with it so they
approach the data scientist and say hey
um you know can't you just calculate
some predictions for that so you know
you have the data and then usually you
have the descriptive part and then you
have the predictive part and then the
prescriptive part so on you look at the
data you gain knowledge you develop a
model and you can calculate predictions
and then you can actually tell what to
do with it and feed it back into the
system and yeah somehow um most
companies don't don't understand what
needs to be done this whole chain to get
from we have some data to what can we do
with it so in 2012 I think on a guy
called Nathan martes worked Twitter
before started actually writing a book
which is called big data and it's about
principles and best practices of
scalable and real-time
data systems and he called it the lambda
architecture and yeah he started writing
it like in 2012 at Manning and they have
these early access program I just
finished and release the final version
this a couple of weeks ago so what he
describes in the in his book in the the
lambda architecture is really how to
design a scalable data processing system
from an integral approach and so it's
not primarily on technologies but it's
about concepts and so he just kind of
takes the different perspective it's not
that we have a problem we look for
technology to solve this but he thinks
about okay what do we want our system to
look like what kind of features do we
want to have and then he thinks about
how to solve this and which technologies
to apply to achieve this you cannot read
this right what a pity huh okay I was
actually a joke included in these lines
well I will describe what's supposed to
be written there and where the the
expression lambda architecture comes
from because one really d principle the
first principle of the lambda
architecture is that you actually you
have data and everything can be
described by curing the data and getting
the answer so you actually want a system
where you can define your query on all
your data and you get the answer and how
we achieve this oh yeah and why it's
called lambda architectures because
lambda is likely this anonymous function
for example in Python so I think that's
where the expression comes from so you
have a function of all data so a lambda
of all data
I know like I said that's a concept I
can abstract concept and yeah actually a
lot of people are adapted this concept
and I think built these lambda
architectures but there is no framework
or something like that to do this um so
every solution is like a single unique
solution to this problem and that yeah
it takes a long time to implement all
the different parts of this approach so
I had the idea okay I'm what we really
need is it is actually a framework which
conforms to this concept and does a lot
of work for you and I started this
project called peach box it's written in
Python and based on the shoulders of
giants and we'll come to that in a
second first of all like what are the
desired features of a big data system
yeah it's supposed to be scalable
obviously it's big data but it must be
flexible and extensible and I put this
in this order because I think that's a
really one of the main features a big
data system has to have which for
example the solutions we develop that
the company I was working for in 2012
them did not have was like you know when
you go from okay i have problem i look
for a technology that solves this and i
integrate the solution to this dedicated
problem then it's not flexible and you
can't change anything but it's essential
because your systems is dynamic and yeah
over time you find more features of your
data maybe or yeah you extract knowledge
and i have new findings and then you
want to feed it back and do something
with it so that's you know when the when
you're at the end of the loop from the
description prediction engine
prescription you want to feed it back
okay so fault tolerance she is obviously
very important
um which is also yeah her together this
means human and machine falter enciso
machine photo rincey can be solved by a
redundancy for example human for
eternity that's harder and the lambda
architecture also has a solution for
this you should always be able to to do
ad hoc queries so your data sits summer
and you want to query the data you want
to you want to see what's in the data
and explore it for example do machine
learning tasks on it and learn something
from your data a lot of systems actually
don't have this or at least two years
ago didn't have this if you were working
with Hadoop it was dead slowly right and
at least if you have been working with
MapReduce jobs like this development
circle Plus also the application and so
on that took ages so that's not really
fun for sure not for data scientists who
want to apply models or do statistical
analytics um furthermore um it should
provide real-time answers to the data or
not um you know not in the sense that
you can create all data and get a
real-time answer but it should have a
real time feature so whenever new data
comes in and it plays a role then the
query should already on take this into
account yeah so the beach box ecosystem
soap each box is as I said an
implementation of the lambda
architecture and involves like a lot of
technologies it's based on spark and I'm
using docker which is particularly
interesting for a development because
you have your image in and you can
install all technologies or components
that you need actually of for
development and then everybody else can
can just use that
kafka it's like a message queue I'm not
going into detail here let's also used
yeah for as a data buffer so you can
send data to Kafka and then it's
consumed by a peach box cassandra is
used for storage we will see that later
and HBase not at the moment but will be
introducing this soon and of course
pythons used to program the whole system
and is it like a glue language um okay
now I've already talked about the
desired features of like a big data
system that's bad what's that all right
I think it's broken we've tried it
before I would try to explain what you
can see here in the slide um I think
you're not going to find a solution
anytime soon that's an image actually
okay I would just try to explain what
you're supposed to see here your data
comes in into your system and then the
lambda architecture foresees actually
two streams of data one is going on the
top and one on the button and this big
data so on we want to have batch
processing so you have a bachelor I'm
reprocess data and batches and like you
with high redundancy and you store your
data in the master data set this is
where your data is stored and we have to
make sure where the data does break so
you process it in the batch layer and
then you provide the results to to the
surfing layer that's what it's called
lets you can think of this as a yeah so
database where you can actually batch
right and randomly access your data
right so that's what the vegetated as
well and in the other stream because you
have this high redundancy here the other
stream actually serves as kind of a
buffer so when the jobs take I don't
know two hours you have like three hours
of data here that are processed in real
time and then at the end um they're
going on their combined your queries so
yeah agree the serving layer you get
information which is like two hours old
and then you combine that with the
information from the speed layer and the
advantage is obviously that I'm here you
you know you only have three hours of
data so that's not not that big and it's
easier to handle um but it's real time
okay um you know the different
components of T lambda architecture that
you will see there in the demo on the
most important things is the data model
and the master data set that's really
where all the relevant data is stored
that comes in
and there you have to take care of that
it doesn't break that you don't lose
this data like everything else can be
reconstructed from this master data set
okay and you have the batch processing
stream and you have the real-time views
for like yeah you process streams and
you have real-time information you have
the serving layer where the results of
the batch layers are stored and made
available randomly and yeah then at the
end you have the combination of the
real-time and serving layer information
so now hands on I selected the data set
that i would like to process today you
all know the Amazon movie reviews and
they publish this data is publicly
available but they also publish the tuna
in the data set already like
pre-processed it looks like this so you
have a product ID user ID profile name
and so on and so forth and this is the
data I want to have a look today so we
will start with the master data set
which means um the first step right so
we will like simulate incoming data
stream from this run out of fire but we
will just send like review by review and
now we will integrate this information
into our master data set so um yeah
that's on conforming to the so-called
fact-based model which means all data
that is coming in is more or less stored
as is um at least regarding the
information which is contained okay so
your notes um yeah you're not updating a
database or something like that so you
keep all the information that you that
you can get so all your transactional
data is still there so whenever
something breaks you can always
reconstruct it and supposed to be
generally true so like every datum gets
a timestamp let's store it and that sits
there like forever okay so the fact
based model actually consists of
different entities some yeah first how
can you see this yes more or less so you
have the notes I would share your
entities in this case its user ID review
ID and a product ID and you actually
store relations between the entities so
in this case I call this like user
review H you call the relations hedges
and the product review ash and um yeah
you're supposed to be like 10 lines so
every entity also can have some
attributes and so that's how I kind of
designed this this model conforming to
this fact based model and represented as
as a graph schema great so now 10 so
those are now are the tasks that we will
now do to integrate the data we will
define this model like programmatically
define a tasked to transform the initial
data that comes in and we'll have some
pipelines to process data and yeah I
will explain everything in detail when
we look at the code okay so
everyone who wants to follow um now
please change into the github repo that
you checked out and then run docker
runned over okay and then this should
initiate a interactive session inside
the darker and i like to use team ox
yeah you can see that right so t max is
a terminal multiplexer real quick you
can open just different terminals with a
controlled be that's like the shortcut
to get into command mode and then you
can for example press C and then it will
open another tab right so now we have to
then you can switch between the tabs
with the control be and n would go to
the next one and P to the previous one
alright so if you're inside the docker
image then there should be a slash peach
box tutorial folder and yeah so you can
show the the structure of this so this
is like a new project um I mean I
prepared everything but now if you would
like to to implement your data structure
from scratch you would start with a on a
white sheet and then you would start
with them actually writing on an app so
you can really think of this as a
framework and might be compared to your
framework like jungle so you know like
15 years ago we were writing HTML code
and then nice frameworks showed up and
our jungle has all these nice features
and you can easily implement your model
your views and so on and so forth
and this is quite similar so you have
different components and you you know
implement some different classes that
inherit features from other classes and
so on and so forth so you would actually
start with the movie reviews app oops
yeah i think i will only show the code
and you can just follow along and when
we start to run it you can also run it
on your computers so you create a new
app and then the next interesting thing
is like you define a task with that I
call task tasks on import movie reviews
sorry then I defined myself in the sub
module and we will have a look at this
in a second okay so that's the first
step create an app create a task so I
put this into tasks importa oh um no
actually one step back I wanted to show
you first how I define the model right
so a definition of the models which
which includes the fields that we want
to store which is on a model important
watch the master sorry it's the master
data set like the data set and this is
now the programmatic description of the
schema you have seen just a few minutes
ago so
by the way you don't have to use them
right you can use any other editor so
what's important is this class inherits
from master data set and then you have
to define a data unit index which has to
be unique because from the data unit
index to rice actually the path where
the data is stored in later on you don't
have to care about it but you have to
make sure other indexes unique ok then
you define a partition key which does
the vertical partitioning for you so you
can you can define a granularity and
yeah I call this true as 0 seconds and a
granularity which is kind of brought now
because yeah the data set we're using a
the sitar is not that back so in order
not to have like a thousand folders with
just 10 entries each i set the
granularity to quite a high value and
the schema so that's quite obvious right
so automatically at us of seconds it's
is added to the to the schema plus other
fields so in this case we have user ID
and review ID and of type string and
yeah our product review ad actually
looks quite similar and the property is
also now so I'm i have set the same
granularity to all these three models
now so that's how it looks like and now
i go back to the actual tasks task which
imports on the data tasks important ok
let's doesn't that's pretty ugly now
okay I think we have to live with that
huh maybe I can
can you still see this hardly the
bloodlines I can I can change the color
skin you know what I think I can change
the color scheme like what would be good
white on black much better okay so this
is some peach box task and all tasks
have a source or different sources and
sinks and they implement an execute
method here so it's that's what you
probably expected to do like you get
your input when by calling like self
source image data and then you get your
data this is actually a spark rdd like i
said everything is based on spark and i
am well i just think that everybody is
kind of familiar with spark I tended to
store a little bit okay so yeah what's
actually nice about spark is our PI
spark and that you can write Python
programs and with like this spark data
data entities and it feels like a real
Python program but there's just so much
going on in the back and you know you
can distribute your data and calculate
it on the cluster and so on and so forth
okay so you get your input data from
your source and then it's being
transformed so this is done by so-called
pipelines so first i define a validator
which just makes sure that actually the
EM fields are set that we
request and that are needed to transform
this and then you can define like
pipeline chain chain so you can change
together pipelines as many as you want
you start with the validator and then
this is again one that we implement in
our application which is the pipeline's
import a user review edge and then you
execute it on the chain and you have
your user review edges that are going to
be stored conforming to the model that
we defined and its absorbed by the sink
in this line yeah so you just hand over
dictionary Python dictionary with the
data and with the model it conforms to
and that's more or less it yeah
following well regarding this example of
the of the user review edges same goes
for product review edges and the
properties at the end of your task so
this is already the end you want to say
safe a payload well I will come to that
in a second because we need to schedule
our tasks so peach box provides a
scheduler and actually that conforms to
the publish-subscribe pattern so
messages are sent and events are created
and with the messages payloads are sent
so um tasks also depend on each other
and yeah one for example depends on the
finish of another one and so it gets the
message of that event and that message
includes information from the task that
it depended on right and so in this case
if you're working with this kind of
source which is part of peach box which
consumes Jason rows are from Kafka i'm
also assuming that you kind of know what
Kafka is
a little bit it's a it's a it's a data
buffer kind of and every datum that
arise in stored and gets gets an index
and kind of art and offset that's how
it's called in Kafka and when it is
consumed the data is actually not not
deleted it's still in the change still
on the buffer but the office of offsets
are adapted appropriately okay so this
is what we want we pass on so the latest
cough cough set on vendors set and yeah
that's it for the import tasks I think
we can have a look at the at this
pipeline and see what it does so this is
an example of a pipeline that you could
implement right it must have an execute
function yeah and then this is what it
does um it just fills row by row all the
entries and it gets a user ID the
product ID timestamp and a review ID
that actually I generate because it's
not provided in the data set and it
returns for each row yeah like a row
that you derive from the class which
defines your model so this is what we
defined earlier smaller master user
review edge and say dr. spark row and
then you hand over all the fields that
you want to get consumed yeah so that's
it for the important so just to recap we
have the app we define the task in the
task we have different pipelines that
can be chained together this is for
example the yeah for the user review
edges
and then the next step what you do is um
you schedule your task okay and I will
try to maybe we will not run each step
but do it once at the very end and it's
wrong and without um okay let me quickly
explain this how does scheduler works
it's really you can think of it as a
programmatic way of defining on a
dependency graph of different tasks it
supports event basic events and then it
supports periodic events so that you can
create an event every every six minutes
run a task every six minutes and it also
provides where do you have it yeah
conditional events so events that depend
on more than one task which makes a lot
of sense because you can you can think
of like running a task every two hours
but it should also depend on the
finishing of the last run because you
don't want to run a task yeah more than
once at the same time and so this is
what is being done here so I defined an
event called import movie reviews start
and this is a conditional event i define
a another event which is called like say
every two minutes it's called every five
minutes but does where then there is
like the importer finished event and
they have the start import is the
conditional event and that depends on
both of these so it's only run when the
last task succeeded successfully yeah
was run successfully and not more often
than every five minutes or two minutes
and then yeah the app has a scheduler
property and then you can say subscribe
and define which task or which yeah
which task subscribes to which event so
the important movie reviews subscribe to
start important obviously so whenever
that sent then this task is started and
then the app is for memory so I
commented out this real-time view on i
think i will first explain the bat view
part and then we can actually start it
and consume some data and no with the
other way around um so for you just open
another tab i think and you can cause
start services oh no i would start to
the services which the framework depends
on locally on separately so i can watch
the deluxe says like kafka kafka
zookeeper server start so keeper
that's this
and okay and so now everything should
work is crossed you can change into the
data directory and they find a simple
caviar producer I can quickly have a
look what this does is just sends
messages to the to the CAF car q I'd
read on the data from the from the
reviews which have the structure that it
showed earlier and yeah and they can be
consumed so there is a time sleep of dot
five seconds it's just not too many
messages so we start this and then it's
like sending messages all the time ok so
I go back to the first terminal window
and then we can run our movie reviews
and hopefully approach if ever someone
finds a good solution to getting rid of
these slf4j messages and really thankful
that's in the problem that you have you
have it in different jars like that's
why it's complaining about
okay okay so um yeah it started um with
sending messages to Kafka and tongue now
the import job guys run every two
minutes I think that's the value that we
said and it has already finished once
now it's waiting for the next execution
rates
yeah so this was the scheduler it is and
now we actually have data in our massive
data set and we can do ad hoc queries
you can start ipython notebooks by
executing the some star notebooks come
on yes and you can go to the browser and
we can play around a little bit with the
data so out of queries a couple of
import statements a pub lib I'm this by
the way the local server is running in
the daughter and s connect into it from
your local machine on or if they don't
go server running on the notebook
service running inside da car and I yeah
yeah exactly okay here i'm creating a
data warehouse d wh that's what i call
it and oh I did um I ran our share scrub
and inside there's hair scoped it's a
fun time
yeah exactly is that everything it's
like the same thank you okay so peach
box comes with a data warehouse and that
is based on a file system so you can
connect different file systems like the
local file system obviously and like
Amazon's at 3s and HDFS will come in the
future as well um now in this tutorial
yeah oh I forgot to delete that no Leon
still running by the way yes sir ronnie
um so you set a path to where the data
sets then i'm importing um the classes
from the models that we defined earlier
and then you can run like queries to the
data warehouse right so you can say
curry by a key range the key range is
this true as of seconds on time stamp
and then you would give it like the
definition of the after class and the
time range so I'm just consuming
everything from 0 to maxint let's have I
executed all of this not sure again okay
it takes a little while shouldn't take
too long um yeah so
so what do we have here that's a spark
data frame yo you get back a spark data
frame confirming to the to the fields
that you defined in the model so you can
say take three look at this so it looks
like you have the reviews right so you
can join of course like different
entities of your data model so now we
have like if we want to have the product
ID plus the properties of the reviews
then we can join this easily like joint
edges and properties are to review some
by the review ID and let's see how many
we've got oh [ __ ] um yeah actually I
forgot to delete the old data warehouse
directories right it doesn't matter I
think still seems to run um yeah so um
probably a lot of you guys some have
attended to talk about the new spark
data frame API and this is also what I'm
using here so I can select different
columns and then yeah hey are we have
like requested data from our data
warehouse and like we haven't cared
about where the data is being stored how
it's being structured and so on and so
forth this is all derived from the
properties of the models yeah and you
can just append data and then query it
real easy and so this is yeah the
possibilities to do either queries and
then you can do all kinds of fun stuff
for example a sample some data and
export it to pandas and work with this
in your in your notebook right
like plot it okay so um yeah so this is
important if you want to explore your
data and then you find new features and
then you decide okay what's like
relevant information that we want to
provide for quick access for if we want
to develop how you could hardly see that
that you want to integrate in your
application whatever is and so if you
want to do like em I you find this I
like like the count of reviews for a
certain product over like the whole time
Ranger are specific time range something
like that right so you've done your
attack Ruiz did your analysis and then
say hey this might be useful for my
application and then you can define your
your your bad shop and put that into the
the so-called sure serving layer is the
picture from a couple of minutes ago so
this is our master data set this is the
serving layer where you batch right and
random the excess data right so for
example on the counts on on the reviews
that's the demo I will show now
and this is then once again defined a
task and also conforming to a model
let's start with the model like the bad
fuse it has a schema and like before all
the fields that we want to do query get
some keys that are variable afterwards
so you can like filter why product ID
score whatever and it's sort in the data
Mart bad fuse um so let's look at the
task definition once more you have
sources now it's not single source got
two sources that depend on a query to
the data warehouse and so you have a
data whereas connector depending on that
on the model of the master data set
alright so um you get your properties
and edges like before and then you're
joining this for example to get the
reviews including the product product ID
and all the features all the properties
and this is again calculated in a
pipeline and then it's absorbed now the
sink where the absorption takes place is
a connector called sink bad for you and
that's currently writing to a Cassandra
database right that's not not too smart
time in the future we would like to
implement HBase because HBase is more
suited so because you can like badge put
your data in big chunks and randomly
accessible at the moment it's Cassandra
ok
um let's have a look at the pipeline
dash views this is also using some new
functionalities from the spark data
frame API where you can define
user-defined functions which come from
the pi spark api and then okay in this
in this batch task I'm aggregating by
hours this is what is what happens here
right so I'm running over my input on a
data frame yeah here's your new
economist calculated each I'm giving
each row the corresponding number of
seconds with our correspondence to a
certain hour this is still called days
what should be ours okay and then it's
it's aggregated okay that's some degree
of of Pi spark now and then once again
you create these rows of your badge view
review model that you defined earlier
ending over like all the properties as
arguments I did this like this because
it doesn't depend on the order so it's
like it should be as easy as possible
and as accessible as possible and then
you write it back ok so you have like
the timestamp corresponding to a certain
hour because it's aggregated it has a
review count for this hour and the
review ID product ID and the rating of
the product um yeah and we have already
run this
this is the reviews that few task and
this is subscribe to this event and
Porter finished right so whenever the
importing has been done then the
batchview processing it started and okay
here's something went wrong but it does
matter so it has already imported data
into the database where it's queryable
and showing you this notebook also to
see how you access that data now okay we
import peach box and then like I said is
written to Cassandra and there is a
Cassandra driver inside peach box that
you can create set the key key space to
batch views and then run queries on it
so you can run a sequel statements ok
that's an object but it's iterable so we
can list it i'm not sure how many
entries this has so the first 10 rows
yeah so it arrived in the database
alright so you have like the product ID
if you Eddie score and like a timestamp
that corresponds to an hour right so has
been processed in a batch view and has
been bak written to a database and I was
randomly accessible so we're done with a
serving layer oops
but as your data size and your incoming
data peruse this takes an hour so so you
have to compensate for that all right
yeah you can see this anyways with the
real-time views and I show you how to
implement these now
once again it's done by a task
definition which is in the screens
module now let's cod reviews and yeah
this consumes data in real time and also
rides it to Cassandra let's have a look
oh that's defined once again we have a
connector for the source in the sink and
now the source is like a cop car Jason
stream so data is still coming into a
giant Jason but now this time the source
is a stream and once again yeah same
pattern right you define your pipelines
like you validate the keys and then I
define another pipeline for transforming
this into the format I want to have it
you're not going to show you this I
silently remove the comment or in front
of the rid the streaming task so this um
doesn't need to be subscribe to anything
it's not it doesn't need to be
integrated into the scheduling because
it runs all the time right it's a stream
so data comes in its process written to
the database so that's why I didn't
appear here now let's see so this is
starting over again and some the stream
processing as well runs so much
simultaneously so let's see if that's
that worked out
Sam why not switching the car there's no
easy way of doing this if anybody knows
how to do that you can add up to CSS but
my love page me together here you go to
the street you grab year that season
CDOT me forget the white a connection is
the size o words I better read it huh
you get an idea um yeah so okay now
curry the real-time events as well same
same pattern again it's like the
Cassandra driver but this time the key
space is called real-time views just
like duplicated you need this one's okay
and I'm executing this end um must brown
stuff here that's what
okay so what I did here is is for the
combination later on we'll see that the
second so the real time use recurring
like all the reviews where product ID
has a certain ID in 30 seconds is this
bigger than lightest timestamp okay and
there is no event in here um so like why
do i do this i extracted like the review
counts from the batchview and do that
again so you have the timestamp and the
count and then you can you can just
extract like the latest time stamp and
then you know how old your data is and
you provide this to the real-time view
and say okay I count all the reviews are
with a bigger timestamp that's it and
actually there is none but now we can
send one um why did I product ideas like
this that's a different product ID let's
do it for the same stir they're wrong
okay now we just send a message to the
to the kafka client that has worked and
now fingers crossed UConn's 20 might
have uncrushed is it started again
that's bad this is the same there is no
error so I descended oh no it's there
even twice so it has arrived so yeah so
this is data that went through the real
time part with their streaming part and
now yeah put this together in one
function this is what is good look like
if you don't combine these two you can
do that in a much nicer ray you find a
class and remember variables and so on
and so forth but let's see the has 14
that's right
send one more as 15th so that's pretty
written um no this is not so exciting
for my message but keep in mind the
whole system is scalable and in
principle can scale out there whatever
size you need because every component is
scalable and that's based on spark cards
based on Cassandra on Capcom all these
technologies can be distributed and a
cluster sure there's really some system
can you yeah yeah I mean you can right
connector to any database you want um
okay I mean um in this case the
eventually consistency doesn't matter
because because spark streaming uses
these mini batches um so you're
consuming data every second and Max and
I know that's that's a bigger issue
actually so yeah the data is not really
real time and I think you don't have to
worry about your Cassandra issue with
this good as he got shot this is a very
holy Cassandra storing data sample yeah
the absorber yeah this is a mess exactly
so when you define your your task let's
see I depend some yeah I can show you
oops so in your and your task definition
right in the initializer and the
constructor you set a certain connector
so yep this is real-time view batchview
or master data set or you want to go one
where you want to or data to go to right
yeah I think I'm more or less done I
don't know um when did we start what
time is it now I have no idea Pittman is
perfect ok ok I think then I can wrap
this up real quick so you saw the land
architecture it has the features of this
batch processing part the serving layer
where you make your results of the batch
process accessible and you account for
the for the high latency and batch
processing with the speed layer which is
you know processing data and streams in
real time and then your query from both
streams and you get sound like yeah
answers which include just recent data
plus which can be based on like heavy
computations and this is like one
feature which is that people always
think of when they hear a loud
architecture but lambda architecture
comes with many more features which are
also relevant if you build a big data
architecture so when you go and put your
own big data architecture there will be
many mistakes I assure you that you will
do many pitfalls and just you know not
everybody needs to make every mistake
every time over and over again
so I highly recommend to read this book
before you that your big data
infrastructure and yeah if you like use
peach books and it's obviously not yet
production ready and its really Airy
state it's all open source it son yeah
license and an open source license so
you're welcome more than welcome to try
it out and contribute and send poor
requests and all that yeah i would like
to mention like Nathan Mars I took some
images from him that you actually could
not see and I would still want to point
you to an interesting project if you're
in this pie spark business which is PI
spark Cassandra which is a connector for
Cassandra to PI spark and the other way
around there exists like a data sex
connector for Scala but not yet the pie
spark interface but they have
implemented that so I thing and it's not
yet very popular but it exists so yeah
with respect to peach box and next steps
are for sure like to stabilize this and
to do some benchmarking to deploy it on
a cluster to integrate HBase to
integrate monitoring all that kind of
stuff to this axis right management for
users and I think there can be much more
convenient functionality for example
that you can reuse pipelines indifferent
very well and the best layer in the
real-time layer is that's always like
one argument that people come up with is
like okay this land architecture is nice
but i have to like implement my business
logics twice and this is also something
like that that Petrarch's tries to avoid
that you can recycle your definitions of
the pipelines and can use in both layers
yeah like I said I'd like to get more
people involved because I think this is
a really useful project from my point of
view this is actually how you build big
data infrastructures I know for example
spark now comes with database came up
with the data Bruce cloud that is a good
example of how to process like big data
yeah Big Data my actually i think you
know you cannot build your big data
system from inside a browser this is not
how I would do it and I think this is
the better approach you have framework
that is actually programmable I forgot
to show you there wow you can you know
every piece every bit of the beach box
you can test in unit tests and that's
very valuable so whoever has built like
databases even our data infrastructures
knows how valuable it is if you can test
what you do ok so um yeah if you're a
developer up and then just check it out
like follow the tutorial try it your
data scientists I you should also like
be interested in this because it was
like turnaround time from the point
where you actually like career your data
look at it to the edori and find a
signal and say hey let's use this model
and um to UM to the yeah I have fed it
back into the system and have the data
ready on the turnaround times as quite
short i would say if you use a framework
like this yeah if you're a company and
you're thinking about like starting a
big data project also you can get in
touch with me yeah you find me on
lincoln on p stone i'll have a link to
the twitter account also that you can
subscribe to that's it folks thanks
what questions answered I check the
package out yeah one just have a look at
the tutorial yeah okay yeah thanks again
I think we can have coffee too
you